but the vision had a Dante's Inferno
masters did this no monsters men America
I guess they don't have the fighting
spirit no more they just do whatever the
[ __ ] Bureau tells them to do
we gotta set this right grace
put the fighting spirit back in the
American people ignite a revolution you
want to strike fear in the Nazis you
want to cause some real [ __ ]
havoc well then you come to the right
minute
you still got some Nazi FICA killer
skills up in you I got a plan that's
gonna send shockwaves throughout the
nation
let's get this freak show
I got a nuke Monsieur fire extinguisher
course that sounds so good you should
join us we could always use more good
people
I'm sorry did you need this boat yes
[ __ ]
they brought this more dollar stars
people gotta know they'll have to take
this [ __ ] no more brothers and sisters
in the United States of America tonight
we have a free people of the resistance
Astrid to become
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]